Thank you
I'm sorry if that's the
scent of me who doesn't have
a child  I think it's a thought
[music] It's a
tangle of memories You thought so seriously You put
my feelings first
Canada is serious about the feelings of the furniture store
Even though it's bad, I
've thought that he might be the one who will make me happy for the rest of my life
I'm sure I like Suwon
I just like long black hair
Music]
I'm a gentleman, but I'm actually a good-natured person, and I'm a good
person, but I'm thinking about people's feelings
.
No
matter how much you say you're annoying, every time I see you,
you're my girlfriend
.
I'll cooperate until now, you're good,
your color